In this lecture, we'll
examine how analytics
can model an expert, in
this case a physician,
in the context of assessing the
quality of healthcare patients
receive, and introduce
a technique called
logistic regression to
achieve this objective.
From the early
2000s, I was a member
of the board of a company
called D2Hawkeye, a medical data
mining company.
The company received
claims data.
These are data
that are generated
when an insured patient
goes to a medical provider
to receive a
diagnosis or to have
a procedure, for example an
x-ray, or to obtain drugs.
The medical providers
need to get compensated,
so the claims data provide
the means for them to be paid.
An important question
is whether we
can assess the quality of health
care given this claims data.
But let's first
ask why assessing
the quality of healthcare
is an important objective.
If one identifies patients
that have low quality care,
one can intervene and improve
outcomes for these patients.
Moreover, assessing
quality correctly
can control costs better.
However, defining quality is a
complex, not well-defined task.
For example, consider
what is involved
when we talk about
the quality of a book.
It is not a well-defined,
algorithmically understood task
of defining such a quality.
Currently, assessing
quality is done
by physicians who are experts
in the health space using
their knowledge, their
expertise, and their intuition.
So how do physicians
assess quality?
Physicians are,
of course, humans
who are limited by
memory and time.
They typically evaluate
quality by examining
a patient's records,
a time consuming
and inefficient process.
Clearly, physicians cannot
assess quality for millions
of patients, and
D2Hawkeye had, indeed,
millions of patients who receive
claims data on a monthly basis
that the quality of them
needs to be assessed.
So the key question
is as follows.
Can we develop analytics
tools that replicate expert
assessment on a large scale?
The goal is to learn from
expert human judgment
by developing a model, interpret
the results of the model,
and further adjust the model
to improve predictability.
The objective is to make
predictions and evaluations
on a large scale basis, to
be able to process millions
of assessing the health care
quality for millions of people.
So the lecture is a
story of using analytics
in identifying poor quality
care using claims data.